hi everyone my name is melanie parker
i'm chief diversity officer for google
I'm joined by James hi Anton our global
head of diversity strategy for this
session all of you in this session today
know the demand for cloud technology
solutions has ramped up dramatically
these few months the need for reliable
tools that help teams collaborate
remotely has never been greater as your
companies make decisions about whether
you're working from home or the office
you might be starting to wonder how that
will impact your workplace culture
you're probably asking questions like
how's the real value of my businesses
workplace culture how might we continue
to foster community and belonging with a
more distributed workforce
how are my company's decisions
influencing its commitment related to
diversity equity and inclusion I'll be
upfront I don't have all the answers I'm
wrestling with the same questions too in
fact our CEO sundar pichai was recently
asked about this he mentioned how our
campuses have been designed to foster
collaboration a community as well as
chance encounters that lead to
innovation but he also said that we're
looking at the data and the feedback
from employees with an eye toward
offering more flexibility to work from
home in the future these conversations
are ongoing and there are still many
unknowns about the future but today what
is clear is we need to have a deep
understanding of our workforce before we
begin to insert Dei into the dialogue in
a meaningful way and one of the key ways
we reveal our understanding of our
workforce and the progress we're making
through DDI is through our diversity
annual report we've published it the
past six years and we just recently
released the 2020 report so today I want
to share with you how we're building a
workforce that reflects all communities
as well as some of the Dei strategies
we're using to cultivate a sense of
belonging at this time
year since 2014 we've published our
diversity annual report we were one of
the first to do so in our industry the
report is anchored on the fact that
there's some underrepresented groups who
have historically been discriminated
against and excluded from opportunities
and who today remain affected by
systemic racism xenophobia and the like
we continually try to look at our data
and capture more nuances about all of
the people who work at Google we always
want to see more humanity in the report
everyone wants to see themselves
reflected and validate it I should also
note that we have supplements to this
data including a survey called self ID
which is global through it we're
starting to expand how we look at our
workforce so with that backdrop I want
to share with you what we're learning
along the way this report provides one
of the largest publicly available Dei
datasets in our industry this data
represents real people who make real
contributions to our mission and our
culture and we must keep in mind that
human element data drives everything
Google does from the way we develop
products to the way we design our
diversity equity and inclusion efforts
before we dive in a couple quick notes
on our data first we include gender data
globally and race in the u.s. around the
world there various government
protections on what data we must collect
as well as what data we cannot collect
this report is aligned with standard
business practices for multinational
corporations even as we find new ways to
collect more globally inclusive data
through self-id second we use a plus
sign in all our racial categories to
indicate multiracial people are quested
to each racial category previously
multiracial people were counted in a
single category which doesn't fully
represent their identity we made this
change to be more inclusive with Dei
most people think of the data
surrounding how our workforce is growing
to better reflect the communities we
serve these changes in our workforce
representation are largely driven by two
inputs hiring and attrition let's start
with hiring Google did well in several
key ways in 2019 when it comes to hiring
we have both tech and non tech jobs at
Google last year we saw the largest
increase for black tech hiring we've
ever measured we also look at new hires
our nooglers as we call them we're
pleased that black nooglers now make up
the largest underrepresented racial
group in non tech hiring we measure
success in other ways too for example a
Googler built tool helped us identify
and remove gender bias from job postings
which helped us to increase women
applicants for many jobs and our
internship program which is remote this
summer continue to build broader
pathways to tech we still want to see
stronger hiring growth and some
underrepresented groups such as Native
American Googlers and we try to focus on
that this year in addition to hiring
it's equally important to focus on
retaining Googlers from all
underrepresented groups with that in
mind our Latin X community is the first
underrepresented group to see attrition
rates for both women and men below the
average a positive development even
though there was a slight increase for
Latin ex women women on average at
Google still had lower attrition rates
than men at the same time attrition
rates for black women are now higher
than average attrition rates how do we
do better with regards to retention one
strategy is we build on what works for
example we have what we call retention
equity teams 84 percent of Googlers who
went through that program have decided
to stay at Google we're already building
on that number this year which is
critically important because retention
is going to play a key role in helping
us achieve our aspirational goals we've
covered
hiring an attrition let's say where
Google landed with representation
overall we saw continued growth and
representation for women globally as
well as for black and Latin X Googlers
in the u.s. we also had the largest
increase in black plus representation
overall and new technical roles since we
began publishing for the second year in
a row we maintained our growth rate of
representation of women in leadership
roles globally we also see further proof
that our internal mobility programs are
paying off last year the increase in
women leadership was attributable mostly
to promotions not hiring and this year
we see a similar trend for our Latin
ex-leaders tracking the annual data is
very useful in working towards goals and
hiring retention and overall
representation let's zoom out a bit and
look at trends over multiple years the
fact is in recent years we have scaled
up our diversity equity and inclusion
initiatives to match the pace of
Google's growth since 2014 Google's
global headcount has increased by 170
percent and our u.s. headcount by 180
percent as you can see the growth rate
of underrepresented Googlers has
generally grown even faster this
demonstrates an ongoing commitment to
what we call responsible growth with
these percentage points representing
thousands of new underrepresented
Googlers joining this data is critically
important and I hope all of you have
taken that first step
to start gathering data to help guide
your Dei strategies and goals but
obviously the work doesn't stop there in
Google's case we're actually working in
a larger context of our societal
responsibility to build a robust diverse
talent pool for our industry we must
only focus on Google's immediate hiring
needs but also on long-term systemic
solutions consider this someone born in
1998 the Year Google was founded
is only now completing University
preparing the next generation workforce
for the increasingly technical nature
work requires long-term partnerships
with government educational initiatives
policymakers and community organizations
and on that note I want to turn it over
to James Langton thank you
as Melanie stated we view our work
within the larger context of our
societal responsibility that we have at
Google to build a robust diverse talent
pool for our industry and that's why in
2019 we strengthened our partnerships
with both local organizations and local
communities and we started to expand the
vision of our work to include not only
education but entire ecosystems in the
communities that we call home we're
addressing these systemic challenges
head-on and we're doing so in order to
responsibly grow our talent and meet
industry demand this past year we
implemented versions of this holistic
strategy in places like Atlanta London
in cities around India by engaging with
not just the educational sector but with
local businesses community organizations
elected officials even urban planning
and real estate developers this reflects
how Google and these communities can
come together to invest in shared
success and realize mutual benefits the
issues that we're facing are systemic
and it's our responsibility to help
address them and invest back into the
communities and infrastructure that
support our growth as Google continues
to grow we have a responsibility to
scale our diversity equity and inclusion
initiatives and increase pathways to
tech in the communities that Google
calls home it's important to think about
the end state here of what we're
actually working towards we think about
diversity equity inclusion this is not
about diversity just for the sake of
diversity this is not just about the
heads that we have sitting at desks but
this is about creating a real sense of
value for the experiences and expertise
that everybody brings to their work
every day and those experiences and
expertise can help improve our company
our products and the services that we
provide but in order to truly unlock
that value
from every one of our employees we need
to ensure that everyone feels included
we need to ensure that everyone feels
like they belong at Google inclusion
means everyone and that also means the
job of creating an inclusive environment
is a job for everyone and Google we
believe this is not just the role of the
diversity team this is a shared
responsibility among every employee that
works at our company and what we need to
do is make sure that we are not just
accelerating this work but that we are
expanding this work and doing so so that
every Googler in particular those from
underrepresented groups experiences an
inclusive workplace on this journey we
can measure how we are doing and we do
measure how we're doing through a series
of internal indexes that we have created
here at Google and also by using
external indexes that we have for
example in 2019 we were proud to file
the disability Equality Index and we use
these indexes to benchmark our efforts
and make improvements as we go along
these indexes are men state they're
guideposts that we use on our journey
when we started reporting in this data
in 2014 we use the data that we had
available on hand at that time and as
Melanie mentioned that's the data that
we had collected through mandatory
government reporting obligations but as
our understanding of diversity equity
and inclusion has grown so too has the
need for a more robust and inclusive
data set and we've responded by
introducing a new data set and that is
self ID the goal of this is to have a
more global and more fully inclusive
data set that we can use to expand our
Dei work in a data-driven way Google is
one of the only companies in our
industry to collect this amount of
information on a global scale and here's
how we've been able to put some of this
data to use so far we've hosted five
women of color summits around the globe
over the past year to ensure that we are
focusing on the intersectional
experiences of women of color and all
the Google offices that we have we've
also used this data to continue to
expand the company-wide goals that we
have around accessibility in addition we
use this data to analyze the company
pulse survey that we do every
and ensure that we are looking at
results by race and gender in addition
to things like disability status
non-binary genders veterans and military
service for the lgbtq+ communities and
age as well when we also think of
inclusive it's important that we are
being inclusive of more demographic
identities but we also want to ensure
that we are being cluesive of more
regions and taking a global approach of
our de I work at Google we have more
than a hundred thousand employees
spanning nearly 60 countries operating
at this level brings a extra layer of
complexity to everything that we do at
the same time we need to balance that by
recognizing diversity equity and
inclusion is unique to every region we
need to ensure that we are understanding
each local context and developing local
strategies in response and this year's
diversity report reflects that work with
nearly half of the content coming from
outside of the United States what you
see on the screen is just part of the
work that we've done over this past year
we are continuing to invest in this work
and we are committed to telling more
global Dei stories about our work as we
go forward all of the work that we've
been talking about highlights how we are
building a culture of belonging and for
more on that I'll turn it over to
Melanie to wrap us up thank you Jim as
we move further into 2020 Google is
anchoring on the common thread that
binds all of our de our efforts along a
describes a vision that we continually
aim to achieve we can't see our
colleagues in person due to covert 19
but it's inspiring to me to see how our
Googlers are finding creative ways to
cultivate a sense of belonging
for example our employee resource groups
are hosting music trivia and dance
parties on Google me our video
conferencing tool groups of Googlers are
also pulling together to volunteer their
time and expertise to important causes
that help communities affected by kovat
19 and on a larger scale Google and
Google or are supporting many
organizations and communities within
Google and across the globe leveraging
our tech and our funds I'm sure that
many of your companies
and your employees have been engaged in
similar activities to the ones I just
described the Kovach 19 situation will
continue to shape all of our de I work
for Google that means we must
continually renew our commitment to
serving communities with the greatest
needs and ensuring equity for all we
have to take steps to help Googlers feel
like they belong even if they aren't
physically back in a Google office just
yet we want to understand what belonging
truly means and what needs to be done so
that all Googlers can continue to help
us co-create our culture and that we
leave no one out I hope that some of the
information that we've shared in our
session today who spurred some ideas for
you to consider in your own DIY work
from how you track workforce
representation to your global Dei
strategies have a great day